so once again welcome to our conference
call on how can salesforce help to
transform your business and with sales
powerhouse make you start employee my
name is ryan scott i'm a salesforce com
certified administrator and i also run a
company called halo vista systems LLC it
is a salesforce com oriented consulting
firm I do a lot of training i do
implementation work i do a lot of
reporting and data i've worked in
several industries I've worked in
non-profit industry construction
renewable energy efficiency I work for a
large manufacturer of construction
equipment so I have a lot of different
programs and and platforms that I've
worked in so I think what we'll do is
we'll go ahead and move on here if there
are any questions that I can knows me
mm-hmm okay why isn't it moving here
there we go so this is called the
roadmap to salesforce success and what
this is this is what salesforce uses for
implementation work so what we'll do
first in the process here is we're going
to identify the key contacts then we'll
define our vision then we'll map our
business objectives will create a
rollout plan will do a small deployment
low complexity a conversation and then
we'll talk about training programs so
identifying key contacts salesforce has
four different key contacts that they
distinctly have names for and refer to
the first one is what they call the
executive sponsor the executive sponsor
is usually a CEO or vp of sales type
person and there are the champion of the
project they set the vision and they
actually have some authority to make
people use the platform this for as far
as user adoption so you know i always
think this person needs to be very
positive in the way that they do things
you know being negative and doing doing
things in a way that is a can be
malignant and it can cause problems even
worse
if you were didn't even use the platform
so you need to be very careful with your
executive sponsor and let them know they
need to be positive and and not be a
negative person at least in my opinion
way more user dodge knowing your project
owner is usually a lot of cases me so if
i'm going to consultant but i do like to
stress that these three here can all be
the same person and in a lot of times in
small firms that's the case so our
project owner their job is to guide the
project to completion they understand
the processes they move they can map
them into Salesforce CRM and the ability
to configure as a process expert and
they also provide continuing training
and support so next we have a system
administrator which is our super user
and usually what I find in small firms
to medium-sized firms is the existing
administrators either everyone in the
company because everybody's an
administrator or it's somebody in inside
sales or someone internally that's kind
of been gifted the Salesforce platform
with with not a whole lot of training so
a lot of times I have to train this
system administrator to a certain
minimum standard of quality so they can
do just the day-to-day application they
manage things they have the ability to
configure they understand the business
process in the industry that they're in
and they provide continuing training and
support and then lastly we have what's
called the power user and the power user
serves as the liaison to users to ensure
the application meets the day-to-day
needs and like I said a lot of times the
project under the administrator and
power user they can all be the same
person or you get a three separate
people with those roles but it's
important to understand what Salesforce
considers a key contact so next thing
we're going to do on our roadmap is
we're going to go and define a vision so
our vision is to build analyze and
maintain efficient business processes
user adoption and ROI using the
salesforce com CRM platform so this is
just a sample one you would get with
your your key contacts sit down and
define this vision excuse me
um so you know this like I said it's
kind of like a mission statement for
Salesforce for the firm and then we have
what's called mapping business
objectives so here's a very simple way
of looking at a business objective map
here we have some leads coming in in
different ways and they kind of funnel
them together and they become total
leads and then there's a qualification
stage where the lead information is
assigned to the correct person and that
person is then tasked with qualifying
that lee and then as time goes on and
some of those leads are going to be
closed and you can see that the itas go
to this close leads bucket now this
doesn't mean in a perfect world that
these leads are getting deleted it just
means they're getting put into a bucket
to where they weren't qualified now and
what we can do over time is we continue
to hit this group of potential customers
down the road with low low cost high
return on investment marketing I
e-newsletters and you know email blasts
and that kind of thing because just
because they aren't qualified now
doesn't mean they won't be in the future
if the lead gets qualified and it moves
through then there's some sort of
proposal that's going to the customer
and then there's a system sale or you're
selling your service or whatever it is
and that is your output of a new
customer so we've just sweet we've
that's just a very simple business
objective map of what it might look like
in a perfect world so then we're going
to do something called a rollout plan so
our rollout plan is a step-by-step
process that will get us to the finish
land is the finishing line as far as
getting an implementation completed so I
don't know what I'm doing your
multifaceted approach to salesforce.com
problems and issues in the probably F
but sorry about that i didn't agrees
this part here i'd say it's just a
multi-faceted approach to implementation
so you'll notice here the first thing we
do is what's called discovery and
basically what discovery is is I'm going
to get booked to every user that
can potentially get my hands on and I'm
going to interview them for say 30 30 to
45 minutes and it's basically we're
going to be you know asking them
questions about their day-to-day
problems with the current system things
that they do repetitive over and over
again you know do they understand the
sales process what do they think the
sales process is because what I'll find
a lot of times in the field is that you
know you ask 10 sales guys what you know
what the sales process is and you'll get
10 different answers so what I want to
do is get a feel for you know how
embedded is a real business process in
the organization and what can I do with
Salesforce to solve these questions
later on so these are just uh some
questions that I've heard in the past
during discovering your views and this
is from the lowliest you know you user
at the bottom of the hierarchy all the
way up to the CEO I want to get a full
spectrum of understanding and the
problems that they have so for instance
here one person instead of snap shops
snapshot of leads north static as they
are in with key metrics that can be
created that would be good or it is
difficult to do data entry wanted by
management when he'll Salesforce is an
intuitive it doesn't mess with calendars
commercial sales managers were
interested in using Salesforce for
project management there's duplication
and in the platform that needs to be
fixed the lead status tracking insight
on the sales process and you know system
to track and follow cons I mean you get
the idea here so all these discovery
interview questions that get answered we
then need to use those answers to design
a solution that not only meets the needs
of the users but also the executives and
everyone in between so next thing we're
going to do is we're going to examine
the current process the in the
organization so what do I mean by that
well I like to use this example being
that I come from an industrial
automation background I kind of think of
everything is automation and in a sales
force to a point is this what I'm
telling you is true but you know a sales
funnel isn't exactly like a bottling
application that's not what I'm saying
I'm saying that there are some
similarities with Salesforce as far
is you have an input of leads at an
output of new customers and there's
processes in between they're trying to
maximize what's going on to have a
higher output because so for instance
here I've got a bottle application and
here I've got a hundred bottles at 100
units per hour and it goes into the
first process on the line and the
capacity is 100 units per hour so
they're 100 units fly through one at a
time no constraint at all the second
process is 75 units per hour so now we
have a backlog of 25 bottles by the time
we get to process three that one only
has 50 units per hour so now we've got
you know 25 and 50 and as far as a
backup and then the last process just
breezes three with 150 units per hour
the point I want you to notice however
is that your output is only as high as
your lowest capacity process meaning
that there's 50 units of process three
that means the maximum house that we can
get out the back end is 50 units so in
this manufacturing process the output is
always equal lowest capacity process no
matter the output of the other processes
so here I'm going to talk about
manufacturing customers and this is just
this is a real world example this is a
company that I worked with some time ago
and can give you an idea of what it
looked like when I came in the door so
in this situation they had a salesforce
platform in use and they've been using
it for about three years during
discovery there was a lot of issues with
not trusting that in the system not
understanding sales force itself or user
adoption so just about everything that
could go wrong with in a Salesforce org
was going wrong and the way that they
did this is they took their leads so
they had with that you know they had
earned media leads and then they had
tradeshow leads and then they had what
they called key marketing initiatives
which are basically on-site demos of
their product so all of those leads
together came to 225 leads a month but
let's just say that it's only 200
because I did the math wrong in this in
this process here it should be 200 these
per month in that total market just bear
with me so at that first qualifications
that capacity at a capacity of 200 leads
per month and a yield of fifty percent
from qualified of you know the initial
200 half of them are not qualified so
that's a hundred needs a month so your
next process is the intermediate sales
step and that has a capacity of 100
leads per month with the yield of ten
percent so you have ten leads a month
going into the closing rate which has
sixty percent of 10 which is six leads
per month and notice that our new
customers is equal to the lowest
capacity process which is the close any
questions so far okay no so now what
we'll do is we'll talk about balancing
this process so what can we do to effect
change to that output number and in this
case we have the same exact situation up
top that we saw before and then the one
on the bottom down here we've got all of
our leads coming in two hundred leads
yields fifty percent same capacity here
if we tweak the yield of twenty percent
from the same capacity 100 that gives us
20 leads a month that moved to the
closing stage so then our yield remains
the same at sixty percent but our
capacity went up to 20 now we've got 12
new customers so you know when you're
when you're adjusting things within your
processes you need to design an engineer
the outcome how many how many leads a
month do we need with our current
capacity in yield in order to you know
meet need to read our bills and then
what can we do with the processes that
exist to tweet them and make them more
more viable so I'll do another one here
but I said notice when the yield is
increased on the intermediate sales step
and the capacity for closing is
increased to 20 leads a month the output
actually doubles here's another
manipulation here we've got 225 leads
sixty percent yield so we went from 50
to 60 which gives us 125 a month and
then we the capacity gets raised from a
hundred to one hundred
25 or it remains the same that's 12 and
a half needs a month our capacity is 12
and athletes yield a sixty percent
that's seven point five weeks or months
that's seven and a half new customers
into the six so we can manipulate yield
process capacity in quality of leads
move them through the process and we can
maximize the number of new customers so
now this one I actually did the math
correctly so basically through lead
qualification and I always say
designating one person where it's their
entire job to qualify leads and schedule
outside sales people so here we have a
situation where we have our leads coming
in 225 at a sixty percent yield is 135
leads a month that gives us 135 leads of
the intermediate step with a fifteen
percent yield so that's 20.25 our
capacity at close is 20.25 with our
yield remaining at 60 that's 12.15 weeks
per month so you can see how you can
really affect changes by just making
little tweaks within the system so
here's the imbalance that I came into
with the company that I've mentioned so
um and this is really interesting and
what i'll do is i'll give you each a
tuna t to answer a question nicholas if
you could just you know write a chat or
something but so here we have what they
call corporate leads and then they have
what they called self generated leads
and the interesting thing here is that
if the leads were self-generated meaning
that the salesperson generated the lead
they got a higher commission than if the
corporation generated the lead um so of
these leads here we had seventeen
hundred and five of them per year coming
into the salesforce platform of those
seventeen hundred and five fifty four
percent remained open forty-six percent
was qualified and only two point three
percent was actually closed and then if
you
on the proposal side we've got a yield
of four point zero five percent that's
30 needs a year and then you'll notice a
ninety percent closing great with 27
systems Sol so they had seventeen
hundred and five leads 27 new customers
so you know it shows that if we can
tweak here and here and get leads into
this closed bin instead of sitting up
here in the open you know how what can
we do here to affect change can anyone
will do care in first care do you can
you give me what do you see here that's
the problem hey are you there let me
hear me yeah I can't right okay yeah it
looks like they're going for the the
leads that are paying a higher rate yeah
and they definitely were so what was
going on is the corporation was handing
these guys a couple hundred beads a
month and they worked what I call
cherry-picking the Leeds so they would
go and they would run through them find
the ones that they know they can sell in
quotation marks the ones that they've
actually sold before that they're
comfortable with so what happens there
is the corporate leads are staying open
and the self generated leads they're
just going to the phone book and
entering everyone they can possibly find
in order to have dibs on that
self-generated lead so they're spending
a lot of time digging around really
doing nothing chasing their tail and the
system when you will yeah I mean that
the system itself is theirs they were
using leads these accounts and councils
opportunities so they had all kinds of
duplication nobody trusted the data
Nicholas could you bring up something
that you think might be wrong with their
process
if not I'll move along here okay I'll
just move along but really the the main
issues here were obviously this
situation where you know they're making
more money for these a terrible decision
another thing is you'll notice at the
proposal end here if you notice that the
proposal end you know that they're only
getting 30 proposals on the table out of
seventeen hundred and five leads I find
that highly difficult belief really
what's going on here is there only
entering the ones they know they're
going to sell so at the back end yeah
that's how you get a ninety percent
close right if you only enter the ones
they're going to close you're going to
have a really high closer but this is
how I set up for an initial you know
review of what's going on and I build
these for the for the client and we walk
through what's actually happening so
once we know what our current process
issues are then we can talk about
qualifying and when you get into our
different processes so here we have a
lead qualification solution so leads can
be filtered and qualified using key
performance indicators and then key
performance indicators are tracked in
the salesforce com it's done in real
time as users enter data so we're
tracking information as we go the data
validation rules ensure that all of the
KPIs are required before the lead could
be saved and I use a large net small net
analogy here so if I'm fishing and
there's lots of fish I might use a
smaller net because it's going to be
easier to catch quality fish if there
are a lot of fish and I might require a
large net so what do I mean by that well
i'm going to show you now so our key
performance indicators and these are
just some examples that I've seen in the
past these are indicators for HVAC firm
heating ventilation air conditioner so
we have a number of trucks that the
business owns number of employees of the
company industry type provided services
trade organizations top-line revenue and
percentage of residential to commercial
business so these might be the key
performance indicators that we need in
order to properly qualify a lead and
then here for example we're going to
designate for warm and hot leads an
example of what a quality lead looks
like so let's say it's the month of June
air conditioner season is about to ramp
up there's lots of fish in the water so
we're going to throw a small net so
we're going to city have to have at
least five trucks at least 15 employees
residential light commercial trade
organization has to be a kanay million
and a half a top-line revenue 20
residential to commercial business so
we're going to isolate in tenish and
throw that net out get get the good fish
and then we're going to instead of
letting the outside salesman chase his
tail and go through weeds and do
repetitive behavior and make phone calls
where no one answers the phone you know
we're going to set them up with these
quality leads and I think optimally
speaking you want someone scheduling
your salespeople for them and you know
with this with the calendar
functionality of Salesforce it's very
easy to do so for cold and dead leads
we're basically going to put them into
the that bucket where we'll head up with
low cost high return on investment
marketing strategies later on down the
line we're not throwing them in the
trash we're just putting them to the
side until they are qualified or here
qualifications and then there's data
validation rules this is a lot of
wording here but it's basically your
data validation rules are just formula
based and it read if it returns a value
of true or false you can then give error
messages that say things like you know
the state must be in this format the
date must be in the correct format this
field must be filled out this is a
required field so we can actually
control our users so that to assure that
we're getting all of our key performance
indicator in
any so that's our lead qualification
process any questions okay so now we'll
discuss the Salesforce platform itself
and and what it does in order to make
life easier for the users at the end of
the tunnel and also being secure so this
is security and access and the first
line of defense for security and access
is called an organization-wide default
and really the question is what can a
user deal with the records that they do
not own there are actually four settings
here the first one is going to be
private which means users can see only
their data and those below them in the
roller and then public read-only users
can view all the data that they can only
edit their info and those below them in
hierarchy meaning so it's it's public
read-only and a lot of times with
smaller firms medium-sized firms i'll
just recommend this public read-only
that way everybody can see everything
but they can't change it unless they are
given access and then there's public
read/write which is you know that's kind
of I really hate doing that because
everybody can do everything everybody's
an admin basically and get into serious
troubles there's also one that is public
read/write transfer as well so the
organization why defaults are going to
be for everyone what can I do with the
records that I do not oh well if you're
gonna these are set to private then if
let's say this is where the role
hierarchy comes in so let's say the
executive here she can see because she
is higher in this vertical movement
through the hierarchy downward she is
able to have access to the individual
records owned by these people and she
can see all of their records she has
access to everything the Western Sales
Director can only see the Eastern so
there's no horizontal movement on the
role hierarchy but this is just a way to
give access
um to records to people that need them
without having to change any
organization wide defaults so it
overrides your organization wide
defaults next we have a hierarchy as it
looks in Salesforce and here we have the
VP of Sales he's got the director and
the director both under him so he can
see everybody all the way down the line
and then we have our eastern sales team
western sales team sitting out here by
themselves that can only see their own
so that's the other hierarchy is just
that vertical movement downward through
the role hierarchy that allows access to
records that you do not own you're a
higher in oil hierarchy so then we have
something called profiles and a profile
is what can a user do with the records
they have access to and they're
basically templates that can be assigned
to individual users so you can create
you can create a profile and then assign
that profile to multiple users and then
they will have the exact same access to
the records that they have access to so
yeah I did you could have vp of sales or
you could have standards sales user
marketing user finance these are all
with different with different page
layouts and different capabilities you
know me maybe they can't edit maybe they
can only read different records and that
sort of thing so then we have what's
called a permission set and a permission
set will give access to records that the
user owns outside of the profile so you
can get additional permissions and
assign them on the user level you can
have multiple permission sets so if
Cindi in inside sales needs to be able
to run reports and her profile does not
allow her to run a report I can assign
Scindia permission set that gives her
the capability she needs the user
standpoint you never have to change
profiles or create a profile for a
single use case to the permission set
because they go a user can only have one
profile they can add multiple brush sets
we have our sharing rules so the years
our role hierarchy and a sharing rule
allows this vertical access through the
role hierarchy we're here you know and
if it was just the straight role
hierarchy you would have this downward
movement well with the CEO can see the
VP and downward but here we have a
situation where this person's records
are being shared with this person who
then it has access to the CEO this way
so we can we can move multiple people in
the role hierarchy and share roles and
subordinates with the several profiles
and we can share with individual users
and then finally we have filled double
security and feel double security is the
highest level of security it overrides
pretty much everything so you can
actually go into individual fields you
can make them required you can add
validation rules and you can make them
required on the page layout as well oops
okay so now let's talk about Salesforce
objects and this is really the really
important thing if you're new to
Salesforce this is this is what I want
you to get out of the class today so
Salesforce standard objects and the
first one we're going to talk about is
called a lead and as you can see here we
have Steven jobs business card I would
love to have that and so will lead is
just that it's a business card it's got
a name it's got a position it's got a
company it's got a phone number you can
have multiple leads in the system for
people that all work at the same company
so you could have 50 leads all with
Apple computer and they would all be
completely separate isolated records so
what has to happen is when you get the
lead in that league gets qualified using
our qualification process and key
performance indicators we're going to
filter those down we're going to cast
our big and small nets and then once
that lead is qualified or closed so if
it gets close it gets tossed into the
closed bucket if it is converted meaning
that if we see that there is an
opportunity for doing business with
maybe they could be a customer that we
want to track they could be an
individual person we want to track it
could be a huge corporation or a
hierarchy of corporations but this lead
it will get converted at some point when
it gets converted it automatically
creates these three new objects so you
get an account a contact and an
opportunity automatically when you get
the convert button the lead goes away so
what happens to the lead well it
converts into these three objects and
the first thing that happens it creates
what's called an account and i like to
call an account a company file account
contains all relevant information about
your interactions with the company
partner person the account houses
opportunities contact info and cases so
anything that you want to track and you
want to be able to associate multiple
contacts with there's an opportunity for
revenue if they're a partner channel
partner if they're a competitor they're
an individual you can make them an
account in Salesforce and then
associated with this account will be a
contact so now a contact is basically
that lead card that has been converted
into a contact and associated with the
account so now when I go into account I
can see not only the company information
in my company file but then I can see a
list of everybody at that company that
I've worked with so you can take leaves
and then transfer them over into
contacts and associated that contact is
automatically associated with the
account the contact object stores
information about people who work at
companies represented by the account
object a contact record contains all
relevant info about the person such as
phone numbers titles and much more with
contacts you can capture all the
personal info you need to develop sales
relationships and the more you are the
more that you are with the company the
more that you're working with a company
the more contacts you'll get you get
kind of a deep wide understanding of who
who who is he with the firm and how
they're related you can even have
reports to and build hierarchies within
their organization that you can view
okay so the last one we need to talk
about is a so an opportunity is just
that it's an opportunity for revenue
what does that mean well when you
convert a lead into an account it
automatically will create an opportunity
that opportunity then is basically three
things it's an estimated close date the
potential amount and the probability
that it will close based on the sales
process or what stage that it's in so
every stage of the sales process for
instance you know negotiating or you
know proposal sent or closed one closed
loss any other stages are going to have
a probability associated with them so
what do opportunities do well they allow
you to track and build a pipeline that
you can use for forecasting they also
can be used an accounting standpoint and
you can see what was sold to whom when
and so you have leads you have accounts
you have contacts and you have
opportunities once again these are a
business card a counselor company file
contacts are individuals associated with
an account and then opportunities are
opportunities for revenue that are
estimated close date probability stage
and a potential amount so now we can
talk a little bit about data import and
export so our data import meaning that
we can use something called the import
wizard or something called the data
loader which will allow us to enter data
into the salesforce com system in the
form of CSV files so the headers on the
csv are the field names and the
individual rows are individual records
and using this this kind of
import/export we can pull information
out or we can put information in we can
insert we can observe meaning that we
can upgrade means that we're going to
take existing records and we're going to
change them up certain is inserting
and updating at the same time so we have
a lot of options here our import wizard
is standard and it has within the
Salesforce platform natively and it has
data validation meaning that it will
match if I could have put in you know
100 leads and I match it based on email
then it's not going to input the
information if the email is the same so
it gives you some semblance of data
validation the issue with the import
wizard is that it has a limited number
of objects that you can use it with use
it for reach you can use it for cases
you can we use it for accounts but you
can't use it for you can use it for
opportunities and then there's a lot of
other objects that you need to fill that
you can't use the import wizard for plus
it only has 50,000 record limit so if
you want to import a million records
then the import Wizards i'm going to do
that for you so then you have to use
something called the data loader and the
data loader is a force input using the
api and it'll do up to 5 million records
and the thing about the data loader is
you just need to realize that you have
to work with ids in order to map
information properly if you have
information improperly the data loader
it is a force input it or put whatever
you want in there so you just have to be
very aware but the idea is that we're
going to clean the data so we're going
to export that out that's that's
corrupted clean that data and then start
with a blank slate in platform and then
import the data back in and then create
added value littles to make sure that it
can't be corrupted in the future so its
export clean import data validation and
that's how you can get good clean data
streams that your sales people trust
that you trust that you know is 99.9
percent clean you are we shooting for
100 but with that or there's always a
little [ __ ] so next we have kind of user
based information so using the the
salesforce com platform there is in
platform there's certain things that you
can do you can log a phone call you can
send you can create a task for yourself
you can create
a reminder for yourself you can create
calendar events you can invite others to
calendar events you can send emails in a
template situation where if you're
sending the same email every day over
and over and over again because you're
going in and personalizing that email
hey Bob nice to see you yesterday and
then you have all this other information
that you always send out what you would
do in sales forces create what's called
an email template and that email
template will pull information from the
database and allow you to create totally
custom and personalized emails that you
can send it a click of a button you can
just say send email select your template
and hit Send and it will go out and it
will have personalized email go out to
your client so you know this the tasking
and time management and email templates
there's letterhead functionality for
newsletters we can we can mass email we
can we can send you newsletters to
multiple customers we can use recording
to filter data and then target market
using Salesforce email templates and
emerging so there's just a lot of
capability for the user to be able to
save lots of time not doing what i call
chasing your tail that redundant
activity over and over again so
individual users can use standard email
templates that can be created to address
common questions initial contact with
potential new customers and any other
commonly sent email communication
another thing we can do is we can have
automated emails go out when a workflow
is triggered so if something happens in
the process and automatic template an
email that is associated with a certain
owner of the record as well as a contact
from the customer we can send out that
email via workflow at any point so if
this happens sent an email out that kind
of thing so just you're building these
processes and raising the capacity and
the quality of the potential clients
that are moving through the system and
questions okay we've talked we've talked
a little bit about data validation rules
and data validation rules this is
actually the same exact slide so yes
it's a true/false relationship that will
not allow users to make errors as far as
the data that's being created one moment
I'm sorry and here we have user
dashboards and reporting so this one is
huge this is probably the best thing in
my opinion about the the salesforce com
platform is the ability to create
dashboards and reports that people can
work with in the field that make them
superhuman as far as customer service so
a dashboard is basically a report in a
component so you would create a report
and then you know you're filtering that
report from the database and then when
you're if you want to use that report
all the time you can mesh it with what's
called a component just basically a
graph or a chart or a table and then
that that component and report can be
placed up to 20 reports and components
can be placed on one user dashboard so
what I'll do is for my clients is out if
especially sales client since i'll have
a dashboard for them personalized to
them and it will have things like how
many open leads do i have today how many
open accounts do I have what's my total
revenue generated this mall what's my
closing rate you know what's unfinished
activities that where the activities
that are over five days old that I
haven't acted on so you can put all this
information directly in front of your
user when they need it and it becomes
just very easy to work with the software
if you have you know everything dialed
in properly and everybody can see what
they need to see they don't see what
they don't need to see and they have
good reports and dashboards they're way
more likely to be more productive I mean
you can get twenty thirty percent return
on investment in the short term if it's
a well-designed system
intuitive and that your users aren't
finding as a task but more than a lie so
what does this being user dashboards on
reports the first thing we want to do
when we're building dashboards and
reports as we want to capture the right
data so sales force recommends that you
start with the standard out-of-the-box
reports and then just customize those so
there's actually four types of reports
available in Salesforce one is just a
tabular report and it's basically a
table they can't be used to create
dashboard components it's basically an
excel sheet the next report is what's
called a summary report and the summary
report is good for grouping you can
group by created day you can group by
record owner you can group by you know
any any number of things where you can
you can have a sheep with different
groupings listed so summary reports are
great because you can then use them as
with components to make dashboards
matrix reports show summaries so
basically you have an x-axis and a
y-axis and it's going to summarize for
both axes so you'd have multiple
groupings and summarized in total based
on you know any number of filtrations
for those reports and then finally we
have what's called a joined report and a
joint report allows you to look up
information off of multiple objects it's
not just you're not just looking at the
account object you can pull up the
account and opportunities and mix that
report together and get information
based on your queries there so after
you've captured the right data you want
to build your reports so when you build
your site you want to build your
dashboard so when you build your
dashboard there's several charts and
things that you can use there's
horizontal bar charts there's vertical
column charts they're great for
geographical stage status information
anything gets a single grouping and then
we have pie donut charts which are good
for displaying data that shows
proportions of a total we have the
funnel and the funnel is great for
showing ordered pick lists such as
so you staged case case status or lead
stage it's also good for quotas and
things because they can see how close
they are I have a picture here of what a
dashboard looks like so here we have
leads converted by week you've got your
weeks on the X here and we can see you
know what are what are we what our lead
situation looks like my week over time
and then we've got opportunities by
stage revenue by four there's a gauge
their here's a nice funnel for a sales
process we've got opportunities close
per month we've got some tables here top
ten opportunities and so you can just
get an idea in of what a dashboard looks
like but if you were to double click on
any of these components you would go to
the report hoods behind it so it's all
it's easy to operate out of a dashboard
you click you know click on here he can
see all the opportunities by stage you
can work directly from that report in
real time as you go and it's it's
powerful stuff especially if it's
designed right so then we're going to
talk about our behavior and so once
we've gotten people to use the system
and we have good user adoption you know
we're in good shape but how do you how
do you get that how do you get people
when monitor your key performance
indicators you've tightened everything
down you're starting to understand your
customers more so now we have to focus
on that user adoption and get results
through changing behavior so you know
managed from the top down encourage
managers run for cast calls directly
from their dashboards many customers
also have the following mandate for
sales if it's not in Salesforce it
doesn't exist that's kind of my mantra
if you want to motivate people you know
for user adoption you have to make sales
force the process for getting paid and
you have to make the statement it does
not in Salesforce it doesn't exist also
you want to include adoption and data
quality metrics so include a dashboard
component attracts faulty data such as
all the accounts with an industry you
know all the council down in industry or
contacts without valid email addresses
you can use reports and filter out all
kinds of cool stuff and then create an
adoption and met
dashboard and just use that to find
Kingston your armor as they say as far
as being an admin and then we have
engaged your user community so don't
make the mistake of tracking stuff
metrics only at the executive level is
so so huge don't have an executive
dashboard that no one can see be very
transparent about what you want your
people to hit and what metrics you are
looking at and allow them to see what
they're seeing all the time you want
transparency you want a positive
attitude and I think if everybody knows
you know what the page is and we're all
on the same page you get a lot better
adoption because then they know what
they're expected to do in a lot of cases
companies are dysfunctional because
nobody knows what the company really
wants they don't create goals they don't
they don't monitor any of these metrics
or anything to understand who's being
successful and who isn't and what to do
when when you have someone that isn't
performing let me do you want to
necessarily fire that person or can you
somehow integrate the Salesforce
platform in such a way that makes them
better IE finding out you know if
there's a certain person that's closing
more sales maybe his automated email
template is the one everyone should be
you know I mean maybe it's it's it's a
situation where that person just needs
to be coaxed okay so back to dashboards
here okay so then I want to talk a
little bit about salesforce1 a lot of
the issues that i have seen from sales
people in the field is the you know i'm
not sitting in front of a computer all
day on sales forms well that's not
necessarily a it's not the problem
really they just don't they give it you
salesforce1 so what I'll do now is I'll
do a little demo here okay so
the salesforce1 platform elog you've log
into it just like you would with your
credentials here whoops okay so i'll go
ahead and login and now we have in the
palm of our hand the salesforce1 mobile
app and essentially what it is is it's a
Facebook style functionality so it's
it's very easy for people to get the
layout and understand and it also walks
the the user through what needs to be
done without being you know obtuse so if
I go to the leads here and click new all
of my lead fields in platform our
existing here and it's just very easy to
go through enter the information needed
open and you know we can we can create a
brand new lead right from our phone all
the information and you can save that
information and you're good to go we can
leave a description here these
descriptions if you have a little
microphone button on your phone you can
speak the answer which is kind of cool
you see here they're not big one there
we go so now it's on a tablet so here we
have
chatter feed and chatter is a way for
people within an organization to
communicate with each other internally
it really is like a facebook
functionality in Salesforce okay so here
we have you know my information is a
user you've got your feed where you can
post information and others that follow
you can see that information you can top
and you can associate them with
opportunities or records and everybody
can be collaborating with in the the
Salesforce platform right from their
phone oh dude this way yes configuration
is necessary to use salesforce1 or is it
or customizing zeros from my perspective
I mean you can customize it if you wish
but I don't okay I don't know the app
and use it all right i think it's it's
it's the way my company is set up i have
one office because of the security
issues and that they are pretty much at
the top of the hierarchy okay so they
use salesforce1 and it's awesome because
all they see is there stuff but i have
all these other offices that kind of
share everything so when they go to use
force one it's so cumbersome because
you're you know arizona is seeing Iowa's
accounts and so I haven't I haven't
started to customize it yet but I think
that I probably have to in order to
streamline it for them yeah that could
be it could okay I just didn't know how
difficult that was I mean for me I you
know I uploaded the thing and it works
you know but here for instance we've got
tasks I can create a task for myself
very simply show me my overdue task and
create new ones I'm just at the touch of
a button
we've got events so calendar events and
they just recently got the calendar
events to where you can create new
calendar events which is really nice so
i can i can actually go into contacts
here i can pull up a contact there we go
and it's going to bring my recent
contacts from last time i use the system
so we'll go into rebecca here and then i
can log a call from here i can actually
call her or i can just log call activity
if I actually called heard from here
it'll throw up the call log after the
falls over so you can say hey you know
here's what happened you can hit your
little microphone button if you're in
the car it just talk out what happened
and then you can relate it to a contact
or you know other objects if you wish
we've also got dashboards they recently
updated this to where not only can you
see the dashboard but you can actually
interact with the report which that
that's awesome too so if you just click
there the report comes up down below it
and you can actually manipulate the
reward yeah I just have to figure out a
way that each office only sees you know
because it's so cumbersome otherwise
mmhmm yeah I would look into it and see
what you can do I haven't really done a
whole lot with customizing okay that to
be honest with you all right um yeah I
mean so this the salesforce1 allows us
to operate in the field in a way that's
easy to understand that most people are
able to use it pretty easily now i will
say that particularly sales force
particularly tends to be slow on
occasion so people do complain about it
being a little slow but considering
adding all of your company's information
in your pocket it's pretty powerful tool
and it's worth it's worth starting to
use okay so where are we now oh I killed
it
okay so yeah it allows you to connect
with all of your different devices here
and you basically have all your company
company information in your pocket which
is pretty cool we also have our training
and adoption schedule so when I do
training for users I usually do a
continuing training program that's
multifaceted and user-oriented so that's
mandatory training sessions of once a
month hour-long sessions with users that
will show pressing the important
techniques and our mats and then I do a
lot of videos where I can act mention
them in shattered and hey see check this
out like you can actually see if they
are watching videos or not and then I
also make myself available for
individual training is needed to coach
users and it kind of is like a
doctor-patient relationship where you
know if they don't want to say something
in the mandatory meeting because they
said it all sounds stupid or something
they can get with me during my office
hours 12 one I can give them that
individual training thing small
complexity what I usually say with sales
forces it's a crawl walk around scenario
start small low complexity get good user
adoption and then once you have good
user adoption you can start tacking on
the bells and whistles and i'll show you
what i mean by that in a moment and then
finally our training program that we
just talked about so one thing I think
that this this particular call I think I
should show a couple of apps because I
think this is how does it make you a
superstar well if I go to LinkedIn here
so now I'm in LinkedIn okay so you'll
notice up here there's a little button
this little button is called absolute
greens not very there you go oh it's not
you know you got it new yeah
so this is a an app called em stuff and
it allows you it integrates with sales
are linked in so now you can see up here
it's showing what I have in the system
for this person in Salesforce if they
aren't in there we can add them we can
add leads we can add contacts we can add
opportunities all right here right from
eps done it's actually in your Google
browser so you can be doing all this
kind of activity from your browser so
you don't even have to have the platform
open notice that if I click here on my
name it will take me to that Salesforce
to contact page so if you need to get
the Salesforce you can easily hop in
there so I've it's a great little tool
apster will give you up to three
licenses completely for free and it's
the full license I'm actually registered
partner for them so if anybody has any
questions regarding AB stud be happy to
you know discussed anything you need
I'll for premier support for EM stuff
but it's just a great little tool that
allows you to work quickly just from a
web browser also there's one that I
actually think is a little better in the
right circumstances we see here go to
gmail this is called Cirrus insight and
Cirrus insight actually works with
Google and also outlook 365 and outlook
2013 I like the Google a little better
but they both work really well see here
hope I don't know
password um unfortunately I can't show
that to you there I'll do this way so
here well we'll just do the little demo
here for Cirrus insight it's actually
pretty good I'm let's see products look
do the gmail product it's the mobile app
they actually have a mobile app as well
yeah it works with the iphone they have
well there we go sorry guys but I think
this really it's it's worth doing this
because it's uh here we go it shows how
easy it is to work within Salesforce
from email and then just set me right
back
I've seen a million these on YouTube and
now I can't find one there it is this is
the one let's get this an here okay so
I'll blow this up so you can see so in
gmail is basically sales or shows up as
a little box in the right-hand corner of
gmail and it allows you to do pretty
much anything you can do in Salesforce
from the email don't get there in a
second okay so you see this little box
on the right-hand side so you can
actually pull leads instantly in to the
plot or directly from email and creating
leads creating contacts all right there
from that little box in email itself I
believe it's nine ninety-nine a month
and I you know I use it pretty
consistently recently I I've been using
the office 365 but somehow i lost my
password and i have to do some digging
around to find my microsoft password so
i could have showed you my demo but you
know we can create events events from
email and everything goes directly the
system and most people that you serious
insight don't even go from the user side
if we end up going into salesforce and
warm very often because it's all right
there it's very easy point-and-click
super fast low cost high return on
investment but so
you know that said I think maybe we've
got a little over but I didn't want to
show you a couple of apps I hope that
you enjoyed the show and if there's any
questions I'd be happy to answer them
now Nick we'll see okay all right that
said I'm going to close down the
recording here everyone say guy
appreciate your time oh go ahead could
you speak a bit on the opportunities for
consulting with in this field sure um
consulting opportunities are huge in
this field you know that's actually what
I do for a living I see there's a lot of
opportunity in right now about sixty
percent of my time is doing training the
other forty percent of my time is spent
doing implementation work I usually work
with small to medium-sized firms up to
you know including 15 million dollars
I'm actually bringing on a couple of
interns right now in order to support
work for me so you know the market is
there's just a huge opportunity for
consulting if you know what you're doing
you know I I worked for several
different employers and what I found
happening in the job market will
Salesforce is people will bring you on
hire you full-time and then after six or
eight months that they let you go
because fix their problems make you know
they don't need you anymore in quotation
marks so I just decided this last job
which was this eres fiel job you know I
was there about six months they laid me
off after I completely revamp their
system you can read some of the reviews
that I have on linkedin regarding this
stuff and it you know you just get sick
of getting laid off eventually
so I started consulting and I haven't
looked back since i did about eight
months ago and you know it's definitely
economically viable and worth a look for
sure i would recommend though if you
don't have any experience in sales force
it might be good to get on somewhere for
a year or two and dive in and get a good
understanding of how it operates in real
one um that's a good question I was at a
company called the Greater Cincinnati
Energy Alliance and we were using
Salesforce when it landed on my desk to
send one report to the department of
energy to get energy conservation
retrofit work and they had through an
API connection into Salesforce they were
collecting data for from a modeling tool
that was then sending that information
into an opportunity object Salesforce
and then they were able to create their
report to send it out but that's all
they were doing with it um so the person
that was doing that report ended up
leaving a firm and landed on my desk and
you know I kind of looked at it and I
realized that it was a CRM and then I
realized it was the best here I might
ever seen and that point it was all kind
of Salesforce for me but yeah I did just
kind of fell into my lap honestly if you
need to get a first gig did you know you
have to get certified that's pretty much
you know and unless you're like me and
you just look into it you have to get
certified and you know i would i would
recommend you know taking the class with
me I will get you to a minimum standard
of quality I'll teach you how past
certification I'll get you the
information you need to pass the
certification and you know you will be
on your way um the questions for
title the administrator certification is
the the first step yep so you're going
to go to Salesforce admin and usually
the second certification in the track is
developer and then after you go to
developer there's a couple of different
tracks if you google Salesforce
certification they have some
documentation on what the different
tracks look like it'd be worth a look no
a developer the first developer
certification is all declarative there's
there's not really a whole lot of coding
in the straight salesforce developer
it's basically a point-and-click
interface that extends the capabilities
of the standard Salesforce platform so
basically you learn the Salesforce
administrator which is your standard
kind of out-of-the-box functionality and
then you get your developer which
teaches you how to extend the viability
of the platform using declarative
statements and then there's also an
advanced developer certification that
requires a new apex language I'm here
Elwha I'll pull it up um it's this page
right here I'll put it in chat for you
there you go but yeah this is it's going
to show you the different credentials
administrators and it shows you you know
the track all the information test
questions that kind of deal that's yeah
that's where I would start thank you I
appreciate you coming in today